on tient souvent l'Europe pour
responsable des mots de notre société
crise économique frontière passoire
bureaucratie déconnecté
au Mouvement Démocrate ce n'est pas
notre vision des choses l'Union
européenne s'est avant tout des femmes
et des hommes défendant haut et forts
les valeurs de démocratie de justice et
d'égalité c'est l'Europe des droits de
l'homme bâti après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale qui a instauré une paix durable
sur notre continent c'est l'Europe de
l'innovation et de la monnaie unique qui
facilite les échanges et qui rassemblent
les peuples Ariane Airbus ou encore la
future constellation de satellites iris
sont autant de projets qui font rayonner
notre savoir-faire c'est l'Europe
sociale qui a permis le développement
harmonieux de tous les pays qui instaure
désormais un salaire minimum sur tout
notre continent et imposera des 2024 une
taxation de 15% minimum sur les
bénéfices des multinationales c'est
l'Europe de la culture et de l'éducation
qui permet désormais à tous nos jeunes
d'étudier et de travailler grâce au
programme
Erasmus plus c'est l'Europe de la
justice qui agit pour la protection de
nos données personnelles pour que nos
fiches de paix nos photos de famille
nos agendas ne soient pas stockés hors
de l'union par des multinationales
américaines ou chinoises
c'est l'Europe de l'écologie qui
soutient une transition responsable de
notre industrie et de nos moyens de
transport en réduisant nos émissions
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
d'ici 2050 c'est l'Europe de
l'agriculture première puissance
mondiale portée par la politique
agricole commune qui agit pour protéger
nos paysans passe à la concurrence
déloyale des autres continents et les
accompagner vers un modèle plus
respectueux de l'environnement mais le
projet européen doit se renforcer pour
faire face au temps de crise face au
retour des populismes de la guerre
portant des politiques communes
bâtissons de grands projets allons plus
loin sur la souveraineté sur la défense
sur la démocratie européenne alors que
le monde se divise et devient de plus en
plus instable défendons la dignité
humaine l'égalité des peuples la liberté
de penser de religion d'expression parce
que l'Europe a été bâtie sur la promesse
de paix agissons en européen pour
défendre ses idéaux nos idéaux
merci l'Europe